there are many options for the world and
energy ahead I think if we look out in
the not so distant future solar power is
going to be of phenomenal
promise especially in the poorest places
often in the tropics there is plenty of
sunshine and seemingly little else right
now in terms of energy availability but
with advances in concentrated solar
thermal power concentrated solar
photovoltaics there are tremendous
tremendous opportunities after all the
the deserts of the world the Sahara the
Atacama the Mojave the Gobi could
provide enough electricity for vast
populous regions of the world
and do it in a clean and sustainable way
at least sustainable for about five
billion years according to the
physicists we'd have a good long-term
clean safe energy system that could
actually be the point of takeoff for
many of the world's poorest regions